Oh Saiga
hello all and welcome to another video
for total war Warhammer my name is Joey
Dalton and I'm joined by Darren with
Nelly who has played through this battle
as the Empire versus the chaos warriors
and there Darren tell us a little bit
about this map where we are and what
you're doing alright so we're in the
northern areas of norske and we're
defending his empire against the chaos
warriors so this is a custom model that
we've played previously or I played it
previously and we're kind of
commentating over it in hindsight like
we've done with the vampire scene
so we're playing at the golden monolith
it's just a really nice looking map it's
also available on the campaign map if
you if you find it on the map you can
just go right there if you wish so I
thought I'd do this in custom battle
it's a good example of defending against
the chaos warriors horde as they come
down into your lovely lush green empire
territories and lay waste to everything
this is a good example of what you can
experience in the campaign and so yeah
so let's take a look really quickly over
at their armies also just to note
everything you see in the chaos warrior
army will be present for you to fight
against whether you pre-order or not
right so here we go this is the chaos
chariot they're armored and they're
anti-infantry they're looking absolutely
badass yeah pretty terrifying I've got a
slight look at their homes
yeah so everything everything with chaos
is embroidered again with skulls and
spikes and metal and just you know like
really really evil looking kind of race
so over here we have the chaos Knights
again armored and shielded you got
flames coming off the hooves of their
cavalry and their eyes as well even the
shields have flames just coming off them
constantly shield are amazing
I've got the chaos of war hands which
are scaly skin they're very fast and a
weak to armor so scale is going to do
like a type of armor yeah so they're
good against missiles essentially and
they're super fast so they can actually
just basically dodge them chaos more
orders which are your kind of basic
infantry you're kind of low tier basic
infantry they're shielded so they're
decent in combat as well but behind them
we have the chaos warriors themselves
which are the armored and shield which
are also armored and shielded they're
kind of just the upgrade to the
Marauders they're much more powerful
much stronger than me lighting and
stronger in defense
then over here we have the chosen these
guys are these guys it's getting pretty
serious now and you get over these guys
they're looking pretty badass they got
even more spikes on their shields that
basically means that they're more
armored and they're more shielded and
they're very very powerful and melee
combat and they have their great weapons
variant over here which means they ditch
the shield and they just use two hands
for their sword for the weapon here and
it's extremely powerful really good
armor piercing damage on them as well so
those are the guys want to watch out for
the most in this battle I think I'm
watching out for this guy that's true
actually so this is the chaos giant
pretty much does what it says on the tin
is massive and he's ripped to shreds
with bones and stuff all through the
skin in this first that's what we got
here
Helicon is really cool it's got like
bulging organic material on the back and
it's like this just insanely massive
death machine that they can wheel around
you said it and here we have the chaos
trolls basically again do with the same
thing they can regenerate they have poor
leadership so what happens a lot with
these guys is they go into combat they
kind of do a lot of damage then they
kind of back out they regenerate and
come back in they can sleep pretty
quickly yeah speaking of I think they
have fleas all over them you can see
them picking picking away at themselves
then over here lastly we have the chaos
war hounds these are the ponies poison
variation so you notice they have a kind
of greenish tint to them as well
basically poisoned those speed damage
and damages your overall strength as
well so when you get attacked by them
you're not as powerful so you want to
watch out for them again just like a
more powerful version of the other
warheads
so the fade to black they're just for
people who are wondering is basically I
have to enable a death command to allow
me to see beyond the fog of war to show
you those units because I'm playing as
the Empire and normally they're hidden
in the tribe so I've just renamed that
went out went back in Here I am playing
as the Empire that's the reich's guard
unit there you might have seen them in
an introducing video they're like really
good shot cavalry and then I just have
some Spears on the flanks these are just
spearmen
pretty basic infantry unit it's worth
mentioning we've got Kyle France
fighting this battle which we get to him
second against our kmb ever chosen I'm a
celestial wizard down here as well
fleshie wizard that you might knows from
black fire paths and the announced
trailer that we did a long time ago a
car friends riding deathclaw up here I
was think deathclaws really cute from
behind because you can see a lot of cars
he's not meant to be cute
now he's ferocious he's got claws on the
front he is ferocious and very menacing
yeah so Kyle Francis got his emblem
Android and on him as well and it's on
his breastplate so over to the army then
we've just got more sword infantry on
the left we've got great swords which
will move over into the center these are
like the really high tier unit you know
they're called great for a reason
they're basically the best you can get
they're very very powerful high tier
sword infantry and I put them in my
front lines really hold off the chaos
worries invasion of like you know the
chosen and the really high tier of Chi
that they're going to throw it
then we have the halberdiers time which
is another empire unit basically another
high tier empire unit that's really good
against anti large so it's they're
perfect for fighting the giant or the
trolls or any kind of category as well
so here we have the hell blaster volley
gun which essentially has like nine
barrels on it it's kind of fires like
almost like a mini gun range right very
short range and then we have the
opposite to that which is hailstorm
rocket battery which is like very long
range and but there's a lot of Splash
Damage so one is very focused in short
range one is very long and and splashy
essentially then Gunners yep these are
the hand Gunners and I've got two of
these at the back just kind of firing
over the artillery as they get close
they're just in range of my frontline as
well so they can fire on any large
monsters that are in the front lines as
well to weaken them that's one of my
favorites here's the luminol capisce
yeah it looks absolutely gorgeous as
well I got the little dude holding the
scroll and his candle and the guy
holding the ball yes you need someone to
hold a candle at the front yeah well you
know well actually they have candles on
the horses as well it's gonna say caches
for anybody very long yeah so we've got
more spearmen than on the flanks so just
kind of gone for a nice balanced build
here I've got a Pegasus with us with a
light wizard on top so we'll get to some
of his spells throughout the battle but
we've never seen a light wizard before I
don't think and they're very very
powerful they're they're kind of more
used for like buffing and using axes
more than a direct average spells but
we'll get to that and then my favorite
unit which is the demographics out in
the woods you're actually hidden over
here and they're very heavy shot cavalry
very good probably the best recovery you
can get but they're very slow and they
look absolutely brilliant with their
shields they're actually like demography
shields and stuff it looks really really
nice so do you have a strategy here with
this or are you just kind of going to
play reactionary and see what what is
going to come at you so I did play
reactionary basically and we'll see that
they throw some things my way that you
just cannot plan for but what I'm doing
here is putting keeping my artillery
back I am down hill which is a problem
but even if I deploy at the front I'm
still going to be finding downhill and I
can't move my artillery anywhere really
I didn't want to just bunch up
completely on the left side you know I
wanted to go for like a nice
aesthetically pleasing battle as well so
just for those of you were going to say
like
you should have been on the left or up
the hills I thought about it but I
thought I could do better from down here
so Joey mentioned it earlier but it's
worth mentioning just one more time so
every unit that you see that we're
playing against or with is in the base
game whether you own any DLC or not this
is what your game will be like when
you're playing against the chaos
warriors however if you do pre-order or
you get the DLC after release you will
get access to players Kaos warriors and
get some extra additional units and some
legendary Lords that is correct and
we'll kind of kickstart in the combat
here with well a lot of artillery fire
yeah so the rocket battery is firing
away and they're firing their health
cannons at me as they move up their
chariots and they're giant and keeping
the army kind of together to move around
the monolith shines in no rush look at
him
no he's just chill easy I was just
casually walking along you just got
smacked by one there and one of the
volleys so it looks it looks fantastic
the flame trails coming out of the chaos
Knights that the sounds are amazing as
well the sounds of the hell cannons
screaming as it goes by I believe it's
like souls or something trapped in the
each each black blast turning souls into
crackling bolts of energy yes you can
kind of hear the whistling and screaming
as they go by I said um speaking enough
very nice this wasn't very nice our
cannon has casted a burning head oh yeah
oh and a flame store on the flame so I'm
almost one after the other straightaway
which is absolutely tearing up my front
line so I guess he didn't like me
tearing up his front line as my
artillery so he just went and did the
same to me but he did a lot of damage my
one of my best units the halberdiers has
lost almost 50 guys I think so that's
quite quite significant so what are you
casting that so I'm casting the net of a
mean top which is a 10 second hex that
stops everybody in their tracks
nobody not in that zone can move so that
allowed me to give it gave myself time
to fire on the giant that's the reason I
did it they're basically to slow them
down too so there's some unity
they don't all hit it once and allows
you to get more shots in before they do
but you can see they very quickly the
chaos nights like over on the left is it
engaged my cavalry they haven't spotted
my demography my plan is to send my
Democrat and a run behind their
artillery now and take out their
artillery every shot they fire with
artillery is damaging my leadership
which is you know what more I'll used to
be in the older games so I don't want my
guys to break and run away you can see
some of the guys are starting to run
actually at the front because of the
giant that causes terror and the trolls
that are encroaching that causes terror
as well so rock cap Carl Franz up to you
stand your ground which is basically
just gives you an instant area of effect
to leadership buff and also enhances a
defense and melee attacks very very
strong you can use it over and over and
over again after like a cool-down period
it doesn't affect the winds of magic
oh you've got the comment of passing
door coming down so they were they were
quite bunched up I think that there they
have a metal saucer in there I mean they
were they were doing something I'm not
too sure what it was actually but you
can see the VFX but they've all bunched
up when they cast that ability obviously
to get the area of effect but it was an
opportune time for my celestial wizard
of fire their giant has actually broke
and started to run away but he could he
could reform so I got my human I could
fire on oh and it was a perfect perfect
hit I think I think it actually brought
him down to like one HP or something and
then one bullet knocked him down from
one of my vendors so that was very very
good nice so you and you seem to have
one maybe two units routing I didn't
want to come back to you now yeah so
they're just routing hopefully like
these units that have like 40 in and are
running away they should come back if
they just get clear of the engagement
for a while so it's going okay yeah it's
going alright we're holding our line
here our spells have kicked off right so
I don't know how you've done I'm quite
intrigued to see what what the result
well I don't want to spoil it and so
we'll just have to just have to wait and
see but so far you're doing pretty well
doing okay I wouldn't yet it's it's been
it's quite tough you know losing in some
areas winning in some others everybody's
engaged somewhere and the guys that are
breaking I'm trying to like reform them
as quick as I can and bring them back in
my Demi grifs now have just engaged
their artillery so hopefully their
artillery will now be offline you can
see them out there yeah there one of
them's actually gone the other ones just
about to go as well excellent TVs a
Democrat Chester white now Oh chariots
in the rear yeah that was a massive
charge the chariots have like insanely
good you know like charge bonuses that
just throw your units around but there's
only four in a unit so oh here I was
actually really worried that arcane was
chasing down my Silesia wizard that's
very fine okay he's going straight for
him and he actually kicks into the
ground he's in a he's in a spot of
trouble I would say so I'm getting my
Gunners to fire on RK on as much as I
can
there nights seem to have gotten the
better of me over there as well they're
kind of now pushing into the center from
behind which is really really dangerous
that is a bold move from RK I'm just to
come directly in but so I had it is but
he's much better than a wizard you
combat he's got a massive flame sword
and so I was trying to quickly activate
his um his chain lightning vortex fell
before he died because I've a lot of
wins in magic that's a very powerful
spell I just managed to get it off
before before he kind of routed so
usually when you're in combat it's very
difficult to enable spells that's why I
had to click in a few times and it did a
good amount of damage if then it kind of
ruled off into the distance and didn't
really hit anybody so I brought like
celestial wizard in I tried to activate
his one which is banishment which is
just another vortex same thing kind of
happened you can see it in the distance
there if so cup some units it kind of
pulls them up towards it like the yet
similar to the purple Sun but the vortex
foals are very good against multiple
units especially in that kind of setup
that you had there where there's many
units all polled in yeah so getting a
bit worried at this point you know a lot
of areas are starting to break there but
they're still kind of bunching up so I
activated those two vortexes really as a
last-ditch effort to kind of annihilate
that section but they didn't quite go as
well as they could have they kind of as
opposed to the flame storm which run
through my frontline my one kind of hit
them initially and then moved off into
nothing and I've so many units they're
just running away now and I'm trying to
see who's available and bring them all
back in it's really really not looking
good at this point yes seven Rotom units
oh no
yeah some of them I've lost some units
or somewhere completely dead never
coming back and it's hard to micro like
trying to zoom in show the combat as
well as micro my Democrats are out this
is not even doing anything so I'm
bringing them into the fight as quick as
I can
getting my celestial wizard who has
gotten away I'm trying to kill RK on so
casting a wind blast on him but I
actually kind of miss and I think the
Yang's behind him well he's dead now yes
he's been chased again I mean RK as a
serious like problem with my celestial
wizard he's gonna take him down so I'm
trying to focus everything on I'm
turning my lumenok actually to face him
as well if I could get a good shot off
and I can and it might actually turn the
tide as well so you dem egress are kind
of coming in there which is good that
downhill yeah they're kind of going
downhill hitting the Marauders as well
Karl Franz is I'm trying to pull him out
of the combat now cuz he's kind of
surrounded
pulling all my sword infantry and
screaming free back into the center as
much as I can but it's not looking good
I mean at this point it's really like I
don't see a way I can win no I've been
quite ad matched now full disclosure I
played this a couple times and I came
very close to winning one time so it is
possible but this time I think magic
just didn't go my way and I didn't micro
very well as I tried to zoom in on
things too much I think but it is
winnable so yeah it's not just yeah
maybe not to pub like me but it takes
practice it is a difficult fight it's
not over yet so we're still like I'm
still I've had to come back from this
kind of thing before where but I have
spent all my magic usually at this kind
of point in the bottle if you've got
enough magic you can still maybe turn
the tide if they bunch up or if you kill
like there they're legendary Lord so
here I was like okay I'm gonna go into
first person mode and just fire directly
on these guys turned out they weren't
minding their guns anymore cuz they were
engaged in combat but Here I am firing
straight on them in first-person mode
you can do this by pressing insert um
problem wasn't was actually kind of
hitting my own like wizard hate around
like wizard I hope I didn't but I think
I did and he's actually routing now as
well so there I am again activating just
the leadership buffs to try and call
these guys back into the fight so come
on guys Karl finds himself as flying
above you demanding that you can't
return to the fight these guys are
terrified into chaos warriors you could
hear them early on
hopefully they literally say it in the
deployment you know like we can't win
this this isn't chaos are too powerful
which is really really cool that's a lot
of Units lost yeah routing units as well
your artillery is now completely offline
yep no no one is manning it my lumenok
it was wavering it just came back and
they're getting crushed by another
charge this is brutal it is and this is
this is what chaos warriors are you know
you're going you're going to play the
game and have to deal with numerous
invasions to be honest they kind of had
higher tier unison I did they had their
you know they're chosen they had four
units of chosen I only had two units of
great swords so
couldn't hold my line as well but I had
more units over also and more magic
wielding in it unfortunately just didn't
go right so this is a last-ditch attempt
to try and kill RK on I fired a magic
missile at him and just missed his
health was actually like quite
considerably low like that it might have
actually done something I called some of
them to route but it wasn't good enough
and now he's completely enveloped so I
think we'll just have a little listen
look at the look at the combat for a
second here when i zoom in oh yeah and I
was trying to get the loom rack again
just to fire and okay and I was doing
everything I could just did if we can
maybe kill him just maybe it might do
something it's been kicked around when
he's activating spells as well to kind
of buff his troops oh the light was just
coming in to help there the lumenok yeah
everyone smith everyone's coming in he
actually just activated the flaming
sword of rune which gave all his units
to 80% weapon damage for 13 seconds so
that's what all the VFX are popping off
now you can see everyone's just like
fighting it out for car friends you know
he's lost and he's not coming back from
this
but he's not going down without a fight
he is like pushing everyone around and
that's it so he broke he ran away and
car fans is hopefully going to get away
and retreat back to outdoors maybe and
defend against another chaos all right
if he can muster his troops well thanks
for showing us that battle Darren and
let us know what you think and what army
composition you would use in the
comments down below thanks for watching
like and subscribe for more videos from
total war Warhammer
you